If you got 4x squared plus 12x plus 9, excellent work. We know that first
rectangle is actually a square, each side is 2x, so, 2x times 2x is 4x squared,
this rectangle would be 2x times 3, which should be 6x. The same is true for
this rectangle,, 2x times 3 makes 6x. And finally for this last rectangle, we
would have 3 times 3, for each of these sides which makes 9. When we multiply 2x
plus 3 by itself, we end up with this perfect square. This perfect square has an
area of 4x squared plus 12x plus 9, which we know isn't equal to 4x squared plus
9. So to answer our original question, no, these are not equal. All the way back
from unit 1, we said that squares can't distribute over sums or differences. If
we only squared the first term and the last term, we miss out on these middle
terms of 6x, these are considered to be linear terms, they only have one
variable with an exponent of 1. I now it's really easy just to think about
squaring each of these terms to get this answer, but in this case, the math goes
against our intuition, it's not true. This is what makes learning math
interesting, and sometimes the patterns aren't exactly what they seem.